it's pretty apparent to most people past
puberty that Disney movies dabble in
more than magic and innocence take
Aladdin which acts like a cute story of
a street-savvy kidnap princess but what
is actually a very weird and
uncomfortable movie when you look a
little deeper here are some of the
things you only notice when watching
Aladdin as an adult gruesome end there
are a lot of deaths in Disney films but
watching as an adult you start to
realize just how brutal a lot of these
movies are for its part Aladdin kills a
lot of people and some pretty gruesome
ways during the song one jump ahead
alone a man is impaled on spikes and a
boo rips a sword out of a guy's throat
likely killing him then there's this guy
from the beginning Thousand apologies
old patient the one you have it in
I had to slit a few throats but I got it
who of course dies horribly just a few
minutes later they're just cartoon
characters sure unless you're a
four-year-old kid who thinks everything
is alive and then you do this to them
but but we loved you Mufasa brothel
friends during the opening song the
Latin winds up in a room with three
scantily dressed women all of whom seem
pretty familiar with him as an adult it
seems pretty clear that he's probably in
a brothel and it's a little suspicious
that the women seem to know Aladdin so
well it gets even worse though when
Aladdin has been Princip I'd buy the
genie and is arriving at the palace he
shows off for his lady friends as he
travels to meet his future wife kind of
makes you see a whole new world in a
very different way rat catchers at the
beginning of the movie the guards send
dozens of men after one street rat for
stealing a loaf of bread as a kid this
seems like a fun way to start off the
movie and introduce Aladdin but as an
adult it's pretty obvious overkill don't
they have better things to do there's
got to be worse crimes going on in
Agrabah than a hungry kid stealing food
all this for a loaf of bread yeah no
kidding maximum effort when Jasmine
leaves the palace she gets into disguise
so that the townsfolk won't notice who
she is except it's the worst disguise
ever Jasmine decides that her disguise
is going to be putting on a hooded robe
and that's it leaving her regular outfit
and crown on underneath even Lois Lane
could have figured out that
she could have at least taken off her
crown that's just lazy
bad monkey when you're a kid a boo seems
like a cute sidekick who provides some
much-needed humor in the films darker
moments however when you're an adult you
pretty quickly come to realize that a
boo is actually the worst a boo is the
one who is reluctant to give his bread
to starving children he's the one who
steals a bunch of apples and jewels even
after Jasmine is already this close to
getting her hand cut off he's the one
that takes that big Ruby in the Cave of
Wonders you know the one that's
obviously a trap and then on top of all
that he decides to cover Aladdin's eyes
as they try to fly away yeah that
adorable monkey loses his appeal for
adult viewers pretty quickly
supersonic carpet you got to love the
magic carpet but how fast can that thing
really fly in a whole new world the
magic carpet takes aladdin and Jasmine
everywhere from Egypt to Greece to move
on all in one night traveling slow
enough that they can still sing a love
song without getting the breath sucked
out of their lungs but to reach all
those places the carpet would have had
to fly ridiculously fast so instead of
this they would have looked more like
this and we get it it's magic in a kids
movie but there have to be some ground
rules even the genie has rules well sort
of genie and consistency when it comes
to wishes the movie can't seem to figure
out what the genie can and can't do
Aladdin tricks the genie to get him out
of the cave without making a wish you
did that on your own
long fool a fish but when Jafar's men
throw Aladdin off the cliff and he's
literally drowning to death two genies
suddenly a stickler for the rules
oh you can't cheat on this one I can't
help you unless you make a wish which
lasts about two seconds until he saves
Aladdin anyway what's going on Genie
Jafar is a creep okay so you probably
noticed this as a kid but it's even more
apparent as an adult just how creepy
Jafar is as a film villain he shows
basically no interest in Jasmine
throughout the film other than marrying
her so he can take over the throne and
then once he takes over the kingdom he
basically makes Jasmine into his sex
slave all to embarrass her
her father even worse Jasmine is
supposedly only 15 years old in the
movie Jafar is meant to be a villain but
watching all this as an adult just makes
you realize how disturbing he really is
it's almost hard to believe that the
Sultan trusts him so much
one thing I pride myself on Japan I'm an
excellent judge of character
excellent judge Shh nah thanks for
watching click the looper icon and
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]